a particle moving moves along a number
line not shown 40 is greater than or
equal to zero its position function s of
T is shown in blue so this is its
position as a function of time its
velocity function V of T is in red its
velocity and its acceleration function a
of T is in green all are graphed with
respect to time T in seconds with the
graphs as an aid answer the questions
below so that's what's going on here so
its position as a function of time
actually let me just draw their number
line that they did not depicts just so
we can really think about this so let's
say this is our number line let's say
that this right over here is the that's
0 that's 1 that is 2 this is negative 1
so we're defining going to the right as
the positive direction so what's
happening here so at time equals 0 at
time equals 0 right over here time
equals 0 s of 0 is 0 and then as time
increases our position increases all the
way until time equals 1 at time equals 1
our position is 2 so time equals 1 our
position is 2 and then our position and
then s of T starts decreasing so we
start it one way to think about it is
and you see we move up we move we move
to the right really fast we get to 2 we
stop at 2 and then we start moving to
the left so one thing so time equals 0
the first second looks like this resume
well slow down and stop and then we
start moving the other way and then we
start drifting notice our position is
good is is decreasing so our position is
decreasing but it's decreasing it ever
slower slower and slower and slower
rates it's not clear if we'll ever get
back to the origin so that's what's
going on here and we see that no matter
which graph we look at our position
function is definitely telling that
story our velocity function which is the
derivative of the position function is
telling you that story out the gate we
have a we have a high positive velocity
but we decelerate quickly and at 1
second our velocity is 0 and then we
start having a negative velocity which
means we're
moving to the left so fast rightward
velocity but we decelerate faster driver
to decelerate quickly stop at time
equals one second and then we start
drifting to the left and the
acceleration also also shows that same
narrative but anyway let's actually
answer the questions the initial
velocity of the particle is blank units
per second I encourage you to pause this
video and answer that well we just said
the velocity lets see a time equals zero
we're at eight units per second so I'll
just put eight right over there the
particle is moving to the right when T
is a part of or when T is in the
interval and they're since they're doing
this as a member of they really want
this kind of in the set notation T is a
member of the interval well when are we
moving to the right we already went over
that we're moving to the right there's a
couple of ways to think about it when
our velocity is greater than so we're
moving to the right when V of T is
greater than zero when V of T is less
than zero we're moving to the left when
V of T is equal to zero with stationary
so when is V of T greater than zero well
it's between T is between T being zero
velocity is definitely positive all the
way to T is one but not including T is
one so I'll put a parenthesis there so
this is equivalent to saying so T is a
member of that interval is equivalent to
saying that zero is less than or equal
to T is less than is less than one once
again the first second we're going at
time zero we're going fast slowed down
and then stopped for a infinitesimal
moment and then we start drifting back
that happens at time equals one we start
drifting back the total distance
traveled by the particle for T in the
interval between zero and three is blank
units so once again I encourage you to
pause the video and try to answer that
the total distance so this is
interesting don't get consistence
confused with displacement if I if I
were to move three to the right and then
I were to move back one to the left the
total distance I've traveled is four the
distance I traveled is four while the
displacement while the displacement
would be a positive
and we could make put a minus 1 there we
moved one to the left so three to the
right one to the left while our
displacement would be a net of positive
to our displacement would be a positive
two so they're asking what's the total
distance traveled so between time 0 and
time 1 between time 0 and time 1 we have
moved we have moved to to the right
we've moved to to the right we've moved
to to the right and then between time 1
and time 3 we move back or to the left
we move half so to the left we move we
move half so what's our total distance
it's going to be 2 to the right plus 1/2
to the left which is going to be 2 point
5 units 2 to the right plus 1/2 to the
left 2 point 5 units and we're done